[music]
>> Hi, I'm Cara and today I'm going to show
you how Firebase and Google AI Studio
can help you bring any app idea to life.
And I'm Sam, I'll be helping to drive
along, too.
First, before we jump into the demo,
let's recap what Firebase is.
Firebase is Google's suite of services
for app development. We help mobile and
web developers build, launch, and grow
their apps.
With Firebase, you can accelerate your
app development using AI and once
launched, you can improve app quality
with testing and monitoring.
And finally, you can drive user
engagement with analytics and messaging
tools.
Firebase currently has millions of
active developers.
Firebase makes it easy to build apps.
Our secure client SDKs allow you to
build your apps on web and mobile
platforms while sharing the same back
end in the cloud.
You can build your app logic just once
from the client.
Using Firebase Auth, you can easily
implement user sign-in and manage user
access to your back ends.
And features like real-time and offline
come out of a box.
That's not all. You don't need to worry
about scaling.
Firebase is serverless and backed by
Google Cloud. The app will scale with
your users without you needing to lift a
finger.
Finally, with AI capabilities as a core
part of our services, Firebase makes it
easy to integrate Gemini API calls in
your app, store embeddings in your
database, and much more.
That's not all. I'm super excited to
announce that Firestore now supports
full-text search. We have a new search
API which allows you to query documents
for arbitrary data, including strings.
Search queries return documents along
with a search score, so you can sort
documents by relevance. We've also added
some fancy knobs to the API that lets
you control retrieval depth, sort order,
and inclusion of synonyms.
Those are great improvements to
Firestore, and we're making them
available in Google AI Studio, too.
Google AI Studio is Google's fastest
path from prompt to production.
AI Studio is a vibe coding solution,
which helps you build and deploy apps
using Google's latest Gemini models.
AI Studio helps prompt Gemini with
intelligent context management and
coding best practices, so you can use
natural language to build apps.
Building an app using AI Studio is
great, but what happens when you want to
store data or let your users log in and
have their own accounts? That's why
we've integrated Firebase into AI
Studio.
If needed, AI Studio can set up
Firestore and Firebase authentication to
turn your prototype into a real app
that's ready for users.
Hey Sam, so I've been kind of stressed,
actually. We've been building out this
talk and there's so many things to do. I
can't figure out if we're behind.
Not to mention, I want to make sure we
remember to celebrate our milestones.
Could we build something to help? Hey
Kara, yes. Let's build an app. What I
love about these new AI tools is that
they make building apps much more
approachable.
It opens up possibilities that seemed
too heavyweight or complex before.
Kara and I have worked together on a ton
of projects at Firebase over the years,
and we've tracked progress in all sorts
of ways. Using plans and documents,
plans and spreadsheets, plans and bugs
and comments. One time, we tracked a
project using a plan I wrote on a
receipt.
But my personal favorite is the Kanban
board.
I love moving cards from idea to in
progress and in progress to done.
What if we made our own tracker just for
this talk?
Here I am in Google AI Studio and I've
got an input box here where I can put in
my idea and let Gemini do the rest.
Let's put it to the test.
I've got my prompt pre-written here.
I'll put it in and read it out as the
model gets going.
Let's build out a team planning app to
plan projects. Make it Kanban style.
Let the users create projects and then
within the projects let them create
tasks and move them from a backlog in
progress and done.
When all the tasks on a project are
done, have a fun celebration. Start
simple for now with no extra
integrations.
When I click build, Gemini will get to
work. AI Studio brings us into the
development environment where Gemini is
interpreting those product requirements
and building out an app.
In the chat here, I can see a view of
what changes are being made including a
view into its thinking progress and the
pre-work it needs to do.
Next, it installs the necessary packages
and gives the app a name.
I love looking at these little drill
downs where I can see how it's thinking
through the problem considering the
features that it needs and building out
the core functionality.
As it does this, I can see the code
starting to appear like creating task
and project types as the core data
structures.
Once more of the code gets built, I can
switch over to preview mode to see the
application live. And just like that,
I've got my new team project tracker.
Let's try it out and see how it works.
I'll create a new project called test
out the new project tracker.
Now I can create a test task like try it
out.
And there it is in the backlog column.
I can move it from the backlog to in
progress.
And I'll widen this to see all the rows
together.
I then move it from in progress to done.
And cool, I got a fun celebration.
The project tracker seems to work pretty
well, but right now it's strictly single
player.
What if I want to share this with my
team?
With Firestore and Firebase
authentication, we can add a backing
database and authentication flow.
So that folks on my team can log in with
their own accounts and share the exact
same view of the project.
Let's try that now by prompting add
Firestore to this project and store the
progress in the database.
AI Studio recognizes this request and
presents a special UI dialogue for this
exact case.
It details how it's going to store the
data using Firestore and then starts the
Firebase setup process.
Under the hood, it's doing a few
different things to get this working.
It creates a Firebase project if needed,
provisions Firestore, and enables
Firebase authentication with Google
sign-in.
Then it takes all of that configuration
and automatically adds it to the applet.
As it goes through the process, you can
see the new files getting created in the
code view.
One of the key things it does is
generate the Firebase blueprint file.
This blueprint records the structure of
the application, tracking the schemas
and data structures the applet is using.
AI Studio also automatically generates
security rules and deploys them to the
database.
Once the database is configured, it
wires up the authentication so that each
user can log in and get their own
personalized view of the applet.
It looks like the generation is done.
Let's try it out.
I'll create a new project,
try out version two, and then create a
task, send it to Cara.
Let's see if this worked.
I'm going to press the share button and
share this applet with Cara.
Thanks, Sam.
Let me try this on my phone.
Okay, I'm signing in.
Let me switch into the project called
try out version two that Sam was on.
Now I see the send to Cara card.
Let's click start task and move it to in
progress.
And now let's mark it complete.
There it is.
It's so easy to track how we're
progressing on our project.
And awesome, your change shows up on my
screen, too.
In just minutes, we've used AI Studio to
build an app with a database and login,
allowing the whole team to share state.
We're so excited about what you're going
to build using AI Studio and Firebase
together, and we'd love to see what's
next.
With a single click of a button,
our app got supercharged with Firestore,
Firebase Auth, and Firebase security
rules.
These products have been around for
almost a decade and are backed by the
scale and reliability of Google Cloud.
Using this Firebase integration means
that your prototype can evolve into a
full-fledged app without the need to
re-architect anything.
Now, did you notice that when I clicked
done, Sam saw it immediately? Real-time
sync and offline functionality are
included by default, so your Vibe app
can feel just as snappy and responsive
as what you're used to, making a great
experience for your end users.
All right, Sam. I think we're ready for
prime time.
I agree.
Using AI Studio, you can refine and
iterate on your app by prompting and
chatting within AI Studio, but in this
case, I think we're feature complete.
Let's publish this.
You can deploy to Cloud Run
from directly within AI Studio.
I'm clicking the publish button,
and boom, there you have it. It's been
published to the web.
AI Studio has a whole gallery of applets
like this that you can remix to make
your own, or you can start from just a
prompt. Check them out at
aistudio.google.com/apps
today. The URL is available in the video
description below.
As Firebase, regardless where you write
or create your code, we want to meet you
there.
This integration with AI Studio showed
how easy it is to create a fully
functional full-stack application with a
cloud database and authentication
system.
If you prefer to work in a local
environment with an IDE like Google
anti-gravity, Cursor, or Cloud Code, we
also have Firebase skills available for
you to achieve everything we just went
through as well.
Check the description below to learn
more about Firebase skills and how to
install it in your IDE of choice.
Thanks for watching, and let us know in
the comments what apps you're building
with AI Studio and Firebase.
>> [music]
[music]